so much about normal life has changed
catherine is 39 weeks pregnant her baby
is due any day now she's been in term
although at the thought that she would
have to give birth here alone because
some New York hospitals have banned
partners from being by the mother site
during labor not having support system
with you it's just New York's governor
has said he will force the band to be
lifted if that happens then been
Catherine's husband will get to see his
daughter born and he will have an added
significance for him more than half a
million people have signed a petition to
get the ban overturned the doula who
started it told us it simply comes down
to a life-and-death decision I am sure
our maternal mortality rate is only
going to increase under these rules and
the United States already has an abysmal
maternal mortality rate people will die
women will die their babies will suffer
people will give birth alone they will
have emergency cesarean sections alone
they will lose their babies alone they
will deal with babies that are sick and
going to NICU alone
they might die alone and that is the
devastating reality of these rules and
they must be overturned
they must be overturned now some women
like Bailey have already decided to move
States to give birth elsewhere
she's going to Pennsylvania scared that
the system in New York is already too
unsafe the no partner policy was sort of
the straw that broke the camel's back
when decisions like this are being made
it just reflects you know panic and how
how desperate the situation is so yeah
for me it's just a red flag and I was
like I have to get out of here because I
don't know that hospitals are safe now I
don't know that they'll I certainly
don't trust that they'll be safe in
three months time when I'm when I'm in
one the social effects of coronavirus
are deep life for so many people has
been turned upside down and it is the
vulnerable who are suffering the most
Alister bunk on Sky News New York